j'ouvre notre second débat c'est un
droit de suite que je vous propose
c'était le 1er décembre 2018 des gilets
jaunes sacaget l'Arc de Triomphe à Paris
faisant basculer le mouvement dans une
dimension insurrectionnelle 5 ans plus
tard que reste-t-il de cette révolte un
parti politique en a-t-il profité que
sont devenus aussi ses milliers de
cahiers de doléan censé donner une
traduction politique au grand débat
d'Emmanuel Macron avant de répondre à
ces questions un reportage il est signé
Fabien raker il s'est
rendu à la rencontre d'ancien gilets
jaunes on est à saint-briux dans les
Côtes d'Armor on est là on est là on est
là ils sont quelques irréductibles
réunis pour célébrer un anniversaire
c'est des gilets jeunes du 17 novembre
2018 ils sont là depuis le début ils ont
jamais lâché depuis 5 ans Tristan Irène
Joë et les autres retrouvent leur place
forte le rond-point de brésillet à la
sortie de saint-briilleeux lieu
emblématique du mouvement des gilets
jaunes en Bretagne si on on avait fait
notre QG quoi
c'était on avait construit une cabane on
avait construit même un dortoir pour
ceux qui restaient surveill le QG des
gilets jaunes non ici c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de bons souvenirs de très bons
souvenirsci on lâche
rien lâche
rien il y a la joie de se retrouver mais
aussi de la colère à cause d'une
situation sociale encore plus précaire
qu'il y a 5 ans en
2018 le carburant
était23 là on 2 € sans arrêt les
kilomètres il rétrécissent pas les
voitures consomment toujours autant mais
le budget essence a été multiplié par de
voire par TR pour certains foyers
pouvoir d'achat prix des carburants les
revendications restent intactes quelques
automobilistes manifestent leur soutien
de quoi donner espoir attristant de voir
le mouvement repartir les revendications
qu'on porte en 2018 on les porte
toujours
aujourd'hui c'est c'est encore plus cher
maintenant et je pense même que ceux
ceux qui nous sout n'est pas il y a 5
ans se rendre compte aujourd'hui que la
vie est compliquée et que maintenant
peut-être qu'ils nous comprennent aussi
du le pourquoi on a été obligé de se
mobiliser mais tous ne croient pas à une
résurrection des gilets jaunes Fabrice
Wette vit à Loudéac ce gilet jaune de la
première heure a pris ses distance avec
le mouvement auquel il reproche de
s'être égaré dans des revendications
Fourtout par exemple au sujet du vaccin
pendant le covid le terro il est fertile
ici il y a pas de souci le pouvoir
d'achat l'augmentation des des loyers
mais m si on la
ressent l'augmentation des prix du
carburant tout tous les éléments sont
réunis pour que il y a un mement un
nouveau momentement contestataire
mais il ne peut avoir lieu que si on
s'appuie sur les bases solide c'est
toujours c'est toujours la même chose
revendiquer pour revendiquer et et
derrière ne pas être capable de
d'expliquer réellement sa revendication
ça va pas nouser à nouveau bien loin
avec son association Fabrice mise sur
l'éducation populaire et organise des
soirées débat auxquels il convie aussi
des élus ces mêmes élus locaux qui en
2018 étaient les premiers interlocuteurs
des gilets jaunes les gilets jaunes
étaient installés ici sur ce terrain que
j'avais mis à disposition effectivement
et il y avait une sorte de camp de base
avec une partie accueil du public et
permanence maire de Plérin ronand
cardraon avait mis ce terrain à la
disposition des gilets jaunes pour
qu'ils y installent leur camp de base
s'il ne reste aujourd'hui aucune trace
de leur passage tout n'est pas rentré
dans l'ordre l'élu local se fait du
souci pour l'avenir de son territoire je
suis très inquiet moi pour les années
qui viennent parce que aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que le gouvernement n'a
pas entendu ce mouvement c'est
regrettable la situation on a une partie
de la population qui s'est encore plus
popérisée théâtre d'une très forte
mobilisation en 2018 la Bretagne
surveille l'étincelle qui pourrait faire
repartir la révolte du pouvoir d'achat
entre résignation et amer
um 5 ans après que reste-t-il des gilets
jaunes la révolte peut-elle renaître on
en débat avec Pascal Perino bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
professeur à Sciences pour Paris et vous
avez été l'un des garants justement du
grand débat nationale entre janvier et
mars 2019 lucide Schmith bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes vice-présidente du
cercle de réflexion la fabrique
écologique et vous publié Emmanuel
Macron à contetemps aux éditions Bayard
Jean-Laurent Cassel bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes J aliste président de maison
Castel cabinet de tendance sur les modes
de vie et les questions de territoire et
puis vous avez publié avec Jérôme
Fourquet la France sous nos yeux c'était
en 2021 aux éditions du Seuil Mathieu
croissandau évidemment est resté à mes
côtés qu'est-ce qui domine d'après vous
Pascal Perino quel sentiment domine
aujourd'hui 5 ans après parmi ces ces
Français qui ont occupé les les
ronds-points ou manifesté est-ce que
c'est l' merertume peut-être la fierté
du souvenir'est non non il y a il y a la
fierté du souvenir j'ai gardé moi un
lien avec de nombreux gilets jaunes que
j'avais rencontré à l'époque et en effet
ils ont l'impression d'avoir participé à
un grand moment un nouveau type aussi de
mouvement social un mouvement social et
en cela ils ont raison c'est un
mouvement social radicalement nouveau
seul quelques années auparavant le
mouvement des bonniss rouges en Bretagne
avait annoncé ce type de mouvement
social qui se fait en dehors de toute
médiation traditionnelle il y avait des
gens qui allaient du rassemblement
national à la France insoumise il y
avait des syndiqués des non syndqués il
y avait c'était la France d'ailleurs
c'est pas pour rien que c'est un
mouvement social c'est très rare qui
s'est fait sous les couleurs nationales
il y avait les couleurs du gilet jaune
il faut interpréter mais il y avait les
couleurs nationales c'est ça
représentait vraiment toute la diversité
toute la diversité française alors bien
sûr comme vient de le dire je crois
quelqu'un de un habitant de Loudéac qui
avait été un ancien gilets jaunes le
terro est fertile c'est arrivé ça peut
arriver à nouveau sous cette même forme
je ne crois pas parce que ce sont des
mouvements qui ne sont pas structurés
sont des mouvements épisodiques qui
s'adapte à l'air du temps mais le le
terrro reste oui bien sûr extrêmement
fertile avec en particulier la question
du pouvoir d'achat et de l'inflation on
on en reparlera largement dans ce débat
lucide Schmith cette France g est-ce que
elle a le sentiment d'avoir été entendue
même partiellement par bah Emmanuel
Macron principalement on va dire le
pouvoir politique non moi je crois que
ce qui ressort de votre portable c'est
qu'effectivement elle se sent euh elle a
l'impression qu'elle n'a pas été
entendue et pour autant ce qui est ce
qui est frappant c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup d'initiatives politiques qui
ont été prises pour dire qu'on
l'entendait c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu ce
grand débat national dont Pascal Perino
était garant il y a eu quand même la
convention sitoyenne pour le climat donc
il faut rappeler que la sociologie avait
été par le tirage au sort était censé se
calquer sur d'une certaine manière la
sociologie des gilets jaunes et donc on
voit bien que la nature des réponses
politiques il y a eu aussi il faut le
rappeler je crois que c'est de l'ordre
de 12 milliards d'euros qui ont été
donnés a-t-on dit au gilets jaunes et du
coup il y avait toute cette discussion
là-dus mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
que donc toutes ces réponses qui ont
quand même été relativement nombreuses
il y a eu une succession de réponses en
fait pendant plusieurs mois non ne les
ont pas satisfait et ce qu'on voit c'est
pourquoi c'està-dire que il faut se
rappeler le caractère hétérogène en fait
des des des revendications en tout cas
de ce mouvement c'estàd qu'il y avait à
la fois des demandes sur le pouvoir
d'achat ça c'est c'est repris il y avait
des demandes démocratiques il faut se
rappeler que le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne c'était une des principales
revendications des des gilets jaunes il
y avait des demandes aussi de nature
écologique par rapport à la méthode en
disant écoutez l'écologie il faut pas
que ça tombe du ciel il faut que ça
vienne du terrain donc tout ça ça a au
fond posé une espèce de euh de question
sans solution euh à nos politiques qui
sont habitués à dire que c'était pas
possible de répondre à toutes ces
questions en même temps c'est ça je je
pense que il y avais tellement de
questions en même temps que le fait
d'avoir choisi de répondre d'abord de
manière financière euh et puis aussi je
me rappelle qu'Emmanuel Macron a employé
le terme d'éc populaire il a dit il faut
créer l'écologie populaire et à ce
moment-là il y a eu cette espèce donc de
mini débat avec déjà Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a dit mais c'est moi qui est dit ça
le premier donc il y a eu cette
discussion absurde et au fond je pense
que donc il y a pas eu la capacité à
répondre à l'ensemble des questions et
que du coup le sentiment qu'on a répondu
à aucune question est très présent si on
essaie d'analyser ce mouvement on a on a
choisi cette date parce qu'on est à
quelques jours de du du 1er décembre 1er
décembre 2018 c'est le le saccage de
l'Arc de Triomphe Jean-Laurent cassli
est-ce que le mouvement change de forme
ce jour-là peut-être surtout dans la
perception par par tous les citoyens
français alors probablement c'est je
pense que c'est resté un mouvement comme
Pascal l'a dit inclassable quelque part
inédit dans dans le livre donc vous avez
rappelé le le titre qu'on a cécrit avec
Jérôme forqu on ouvre vraiment
l'introduction la première ligne de la
première page par le mouvement des
gilets jaunes parce qu'on avait
l'impression que dans ce dans ces
quelques semaines ces quelques mois de
mobilisation s'est joué vraiment une une
véritable mise à jour du du du pays sur
plusieurs plans déjà sur le plan je
dirais des fractures géographiques
spatial territorial aujourd'hui c'est
une évidence avec le recul 5 ans après
mais à l'époque quand moi je me rappelle
j'étais journaliste à Slate à l'époque
et je je regardais en amont de la de la
de l'acte 1 donc avant avant ce 1er
décembre dont vous parliez en Amon de la
première mobilisation décemb c'est
l'acte 3 c'est l'acte 3 pardon donc je
dis bien avant l'acte le 18 novembre
l'acte 1 je m'intéressais à à ces lieu
de rassemblement déjà au fait que ce
soit organisé par des groupes facebook
et que ces groupes indiqués au futurs
gilets Jaun ils allaient se retrouver
qui devant le parking du McDo qui devant
le rond-point de Bricorama ou de Kings
de jouet et en fait on on on voyait
finalement euh toute cette urbanisation
des des des périphéries des des 30 40
dernières années explosé jailleur sous
nos yeux puisque c'était les gilets
jaunes étaient devenus le peuple de la
route le peuple de ces de ces
périphéries et ça c'était un premier
élément l'autre élément que je trouve
très présent qui a été très présent à
l'époque c'est l'évolution de la
structure sociale puisqueen fait ce
qu'on a vu aussi c'est une forme de
lutte des classes philosophe et sociolog
Bruno Latour qui est décédé l'année
dernière parlait de de classe géosociale
on a vu à quel point les catégories
sociales ont ont évolué les les les les
vieilles les vieux bastions ouvriers ont
quelque part été remplacés par par les
caristes les les les les professionnels
de la logistiqu les les aides soignantes
tous ce prolétariat en fait des services
des services à la personne des services
aux entreprises qui bien souvent a
remplacé l'ouvrier d'usine c'est un peu
comme si le gilet jaune était devenu le
nouveau bleu de travail et le
l'anthropologistique la nouvelle la
nouvelle usine d'ailleurs il y avait
beaucoup de charistes parmi les gilets
jaunes qui ont été arrêtés pendant le
sacage du du 1er décembre ouais et donc
je repose la la même question sur on a
commencé à parler de gilets jaunes
radicalisé Pascal Pascal Perino donc
c'est c'est c'est intéressant la
perception du mouvement dans dans le
temps et moi je pense l'avant après AR
de Triomphe non bien sûr il y a vous
savez dans tous les mouvements sociaux à
partir d'un moment où il dure il y a une
radicalisation hein il y aller jusqu'au
bouist il y a ceux qui veulent arrêter
il y a ceux qui veulent se donner le
temps de de réfléchir à l'organisation
au formes d'action et le mouvement des
gilets jaunes oui a connu une
radicalisation euh certains radicaux
d'ailleurs venant à la fois de l'extrême
gauche comme de l'extrême droite s'en
sont occupés c'est-à-dire se sont
introduits dans ce mouvement qui en plus
de ça n'avait pas de service d'ordre
était dans un état de désorganisation
parce qu'ils refusaient eux-mêmes toute
forme d'organisation c'est un mouvement
très facile à pénétrer donc des
minorités s'en sont occupées et d'après
les enquêtes qui ont été faites par la
police à propos de ce saccage sinistre
en effet qui s'est développé à l'Arc de
Triomphe il y avait il y avait des
militants radicaux et en particulier des
militants radicaux de l'extrême droite
hein donc bien sûr il y a eu une
radicalisation et puis les gilets jaunes
eux mêmes se sont radicalisés
c'est-à-dire il y a eu de la violence
produite par des gilets jaunes par des
gens très souvent vous savez on parlait
de Primo manifestants des gens qui
n'avaient jamais manifester de leur vie
jamais manifester de leur vie et on a vu
des vieilles dames très dignes en gilets
jaunes se mettre à prendre une bouteille
et à l'acheter sur les forces de l'ordre
et cetera donc oui il y a une
radicalisation du mouvement qui était
peut-être d au fait que ce mouvement est
très original et à la fois très français
très original parce qu'il ne se donne
pas les moyens de déboucher politiques
mais oui il y a eu zéro des bouchés
politiques VO et pourquoi très français
pas de tête d'affiche qui a qui qui a
pris le qui a pris le pas sur il y eu
plusieurs mais il y en a eu aucune qui a
émergé quoi depuis la Révolution
française il y a ce tempérament qui
considère que la souveraineté populaire
ne peut pas être représenté c'est
Robespierre qui le disait Rousseau le
disait d'une autre manière auparavant
c'est-à-dire on ne peut pas être
représenté et on l'a vu c'était farouche
dans ce mouvement dès qu'il y avait un
leader des gilets jaunes qui montrait sa
tête on lui coupait
la plateau tél plate de télé était
considéré comme un vendu aux médias et
cetera donc on s'en occupait pour
l'écarter donc ce mouvement est en cela
extrêmement franco-français hein euh et
cette vous savez il y a un slogani qui
m'a toujours frappé d'ailleurs je crois
que ça a été
photographié on voyait en plein
mouvement des gilets jaunes une jeune
femme avec son gilet qui était en train
d'écrire sur un mur noir nous ne voulons
pas discuter trois petits points tout
est dit là-dedans hein nous ne voulons
pas discuter nous sommes très en colère
mais on veut pas discuter on veut pas
s'organiser pour discuter on veut
simplement exprimer notre radbol et ça
bien sûr le radbol il est toujours là
alors justement on le dit les ferm de la
révolte il sont toujours présents
écoutez ce fonctionnaire qui manifestait
là pour le 5e anniversaire c'était le 18
novembre dernier il s'appelle
François malheureusement on est toujours
au même point c'est même pire quand on
voit le coûp de la vie l'inflation le
carburant l'alimentation les droits
sociaux qui malheureusement diminuent de
plus en plus donc voilà c'est voilà même
si malheureusement il y a moins de monde
dans la rue que qu'au début malgré tout
mais voilà la mobilisation reste là et
affaiblit pas voilà mouvement qui était
lié sur des questions de de pouvoir
d'achat de évidemment de mouvement parti
de la route des usagers de la route d'où
le le le gilet jaune avec cette
idée fin de fin du monde fin de mois
lucide Schmidt est-ce que ça ça a évolué
dans la perception des des Français qui
participaient au gilets jaunes et qui
disent aujourd'hui bon ben il y a que
toujours il y a toujours les ferment de
la de la révolte est-ce qu'ils ont
évolué sur cette question d'égologie
d'après vous alors l'expression fin du
monde fin de mois faut peut-être
rappeler expression de Nicolas H qui en
fait permet d'opposer d'une certaine
manière la question des inégalités
sociales et la question de l'urgence
écologique moi je voudrais d'abord
rappeler que d'emblé un certain nombre
de gilets jaunes pas tous mais comme le
rappelait à la fois Pascal Perino et
Jean-Laurent casselli la vérité c'est
que c'est un mouvement hétérogène un
certain nombre de gilets jaunes ont tenu
à dire qu'il n'étaiit pas contre
l'écologie d'emblé c'est-à-dire qu'ils
étaient contre une taxe carbone qui
tombe du ciel mais ils étaient pas
contre l'écologie d'ailleurs Priscilla
ludovski qui était une des figures des
gilets jaunes elle va être sur la liste
européenne des ver et et donc Priscilla
Ludowski a a été fondatrice avec une
pétition qu'elle a lancé sur le coût du
carburant en fait en septembre 2018 donc
c'est intéressant c'est que voilà
d'emblé l'opposition entre fin du monde
et fin de mois a été récusée par un
certain nombre de gilets jaunes après ce
qui s'est passé depuis 5 ans c'est qu'en
fait on a été rattrapé à la fois par
l'urgence sociale et par l'urgence
écologique et en fait nous comprenons
tous à mon avis la société française
comprend c'est d'ailleurs dit dans votre
reportage sans doute mieux les
difficultés des gilets jaunes face à un
contexte d'inflation dans lequel la
question du pouvoir d'achat et de la
précarité dépasse sans doute assez
largement ce mouvement et par ailleurs
la façon dont l'urgence écologique gagne
avec ces catastrophes climatiques fait
que ça à mon avis l'antagonisme entre
ces deux choses est quelque chose qui
est euh enfin voilà elle n'existe plus
voilà ce que je pense il y a un truc qui
a changé c'est dans l'œil des politiques
l'exécutif c'est la la peur de la
giléjonisation c'est devenu une espèce
de refrain qu'on entend au moindre
événement une grande partie de la
politique
pour lutter contre l'inflation enfin de
toutes les mesures qui ont été mises en
place découle aussi de cette prise de
conscience qui a eu lieu quand même à
l'automne 2018 avec ce ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes autre chose une un autre
facteur qu'on avait cité comme quelque
chose qui avait provoqué aussi ce
mouvement qui était cette décision de de
baisser vous souvenez la vitesse sur les
routes
départementales 90 à 80 voilà et qui
avait mis en colère beaucoup de gens et
qui avait été prise comme cette une
décision venue d'en haut qui ne tient
pas de notre compte de notre réalité
locale oui c'est dangereux de rouler
vite mais sur cette routeel moi je peux
vous dire qu'en tout cas on peut y aller
à 80 il y a aucun souci cette idée d'un
pouvoir déconnecté ça aussi c'est
quelque chose qui a beaucoup obsédé par
la suite euh l'exécutif alors je je dis
pas qu'ils ont tout bien fait ou qu'ils
ont tiré toutes les leçons mais en tout
cas je sais que ça ça a beaucoup obsédé
dans certains ministères et dans et par
rapport à ce que dit Mathieu moi je
vourais insister sur une chose c'est
qu'on nous a montré quelqu'un qui s'est
qualifié de fonctionnaire oui et en même
temps il a un gilet jaune et je pense
qu'une des principales revendications
des gilets jaunes c'était tout de même
qui est davantage de service publics qui
est davantage de au fond de
fonctionnaires dans ces territoires et
je trouvais que c'tare une sorte de
paradoxe oui euh en tout cas pas de taxe
carbone qui tombe du ciel et qui donne
le sentiment qu'elles sont injustes par
rapport aux classes sociales défavorisé
pas moins d'impôt mais un impôt plus
juste jeanl sur cette question des
enjeux on va dire environnementaux euh
euh il y a aussi du climatoscepticisme
dans la société française on va pas
faire comme si ça existait pas est-ce
que elle recoupe parfois une partie du
mouvement des gilets jaunes même si j'ai
bien entendu vos argum sur le fait que
il était pas forcément caricaturaux sur
sur les enjeux écologiques ouais alors
sur sur l'écologie il y a un paradoxe
donc le une étude récente de l'ADEM qui
accompagn d'ailleurs la fameuse campagne
dont on a beaucoup parlé sur la la
sobriété
euh montre enistre les dévendeurs les
fameux dévendeurs enregistreent que
franç av voilà et enregistre que 8
Français sur 10 sont éanxieux sont donc
concernés par la crise climatique dans
toutes les catégories sociales dans tous
les âges ch par rapport à il y a 5 ans
en arrière c'est quelque chose de
relativement nouveau il y a une sorte de
massification de diff de diffusion de la
préoccupation écologique qui est plus un
truc de Bobo de centr-ville diplômé pour
aller vite euh bon une fois qu'on a dit
ça la la transition écologique est aussi
en train de se traduire en loi et en
dispositifs de plus en plus concrets et
de plus en plus contraignant à à court
terme trois exemples désolé pour
l'avalangeche de sigles ZFE zan d pe
doncqute pas on a fait une émission
là-dessus il y a pas TR longtemps quand
on était au salon des m on a bien vu à
quel point ça être un cetette pour eux
voilà donc je je ZFE zone à faible
émission qui exclut progressivement les
voitures les les plus polluant des des
agglomérations zan zéro
artificialisation net qui à terme
dispose qu'il n'y aura plus de de
possibilité de construire autour des des
des petites villes sans compensation
ailleurs et enfin des PE la la question
des passoirs énergétiques on sur tous
ces dispositifs la plupart des Français
disent bah oui on est pour c'est du bon
sens moins de pollution dans les villes
moins d'art artificialisation des sols
moins de de de passoir thermique le
problème c'est que quand ça tombe sur
vous c'est comme les niches fiscales en
fait il y a toujours un chien intérieur
et là dans dans chacun de ces
dispositifs il y a une contradiction
entre je pense un accord de principe
pour pour des changements voilà
structurel du rythme du rythme de la
transition écologique juste pour finir
et surtout le coût de la transition
écologique c'estàd que la voiture
électrique avoir un un un logement plus
sobre en terme d'énergie et euh et voilà
et et euh tout ça ça coûte plus cher
voilàou alors on on a on a commencé à
l'évoquer grâce à vous lucde Schmith
mais on va rentrer dans le détail de de
ce que les gilets jaunes ont obtenu
grâce à Steve Jourdain qui va pouvoir
revenir sur le plateau de sens public
rebonsoir Steve Emmanuel Macron et son
premier ministre édard Philippe qui
avait sorti de Chequer oui première
mobilisation des gilets jaunes le 17
novembre 2018 300000 personnes
descendent dans la rue dans la foulée
l'exécutif effectivement va tenter de
désamorcer le mouvement en faisant
plusieurs annonces la taxe carbone sur
les carburants est enterrée défin
tivement mais il faut attendre le 10
décembre presque un mois après le début
de la mobilisation pour qu'Emmanuel
Macron prenne enfin la parole et
s'adresse directement au gilet jaune
écouter je prends ma part de cette
responsabilité il a pu m'arriver de vous
donner le sentiment que ce n'était pas
mon souci que j'avais d'autres
priorités je sais aussi qu'il m'est
arrivé de blesser certains d'entre vous
par mes propos Emmanuel Macron a fait
plusieurs annonces à l'occasion de cette
aloc parmi elle la hausse de 100 € pour
le une hausse de 100 € pour les
travailleurs osmqu une exonération de
cotisation et la généralisation des
primes de fin d'année l'annulation de la
hausse de la CSG pour une partie des
retraités ou encore l'organisation d'un
grand débat national avec pour objectif
et bien de répondre au malaise
démocratique ce débat se déroulera de
décembre à mars 2019 il passe par
l'ouverture de cahett doléance dans
toutes les mairies de France c'est un
certain Pascal Perino qui est garant de
ce grand débat et ce n'est pas suffisant
pour calmer la colère des gilets jaunes
non il continue à se mobiliser dans dans
les semaines qui suivent les
revendications se multiplient Emmanuel
Macron va promettre de nouveau milliards
on est fin avril 2019 le chef de l'État
est conclu comme ça les 3 mois du grand
débat on va écouter le chef de l'État je
ne veux pas que les dérives de
quelques-uns
occulent les justes revendication porté
à l'origine de ce mouvement et
profondément soutenu l'impatience
l'exigence que j'ai avec moi-même que
j'ai avec les membres du gouvernement je
l'ai un peu eu avec les Français et donc
le sentiment que j'ai donné c'était
forme d'injonction permanente d'être dur
parfois
injuste ça je le regrette
Emmanuel Macron annonce plusieurs
mesures notamment la réduction de
l'impôt sur le revenu la réindexation
des petites retraites sur l'inflation
l'instauration d'une dose de
proportionnelle au législatif ou encore
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
des promesses qui ne seront que
partiellement très partiellement tenu la
réduction de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est
oui il a baissé pour les foyers des
premières tranches 5 milliards d'euros
en moins pour 15 millions de Français
sur l'année 2020 en revanche sur la
réforme des institutions le bilan est
plutôt maigre pour ne pas dire nul la
meilleure illustration c'est peut-être
ces cahier de doléance et cahers de
doléance qui sont effectivement issu du
grand débat et qui prennent aujourd'hui
la poussière dans les archives
départementales merci beaucoup Steve
Pascal Perino forcément je me tourne
vers vous sur ces cahiers de doléance je
crois qu'on on les appelé officiellement
cahier citoyen
c'est une mine c'est mine qu'est-ce
qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve alors
c'est difficile de répondre à la
question mais dans les grand des
revendications tous azimutes qui
viennent d'en bas et qui sont formulées
avec le vocabulaire le mode d'expression
des gens d'en bas h voilà euh si vous
voulez quand j'étais étudiant j'avais lu
dans mon département
l'indrloire où je faisais mes études
j'avais lu les cahiers de doléance de la
ré Révolution française et j'avais été
mais ému par la lecture de ces cahetes
de doléance où on sentait vraiment toute
la société française de 1788 1789 là je
vous assure pour en avoir eu j'en ai eu
des centaines dans mon bureau à une
époque et les avoir lu attentivement il
y avait la même émotion en lisant cela
mais alors bien sûr le registre de
doléance de revendication citoyenne
était extrêmement large Emmanuel Macron
dans le grand débat national a voulu
faire
rentrer ça dans quatre thèmes mais ça ça
allait de questions démocratiques à des
questions sociales à des questions de
mode de vie à des question beaucoup
territorial et aussi on sentait dans ces
Cahet quelque chose à mon avis de
décisif une demande de reconnaissance
c'était des gens de peu comme dit Pierre
sensau des gens de peu qui demandaient
dont on ne parle jamais ni dans les
médias ni en matière politique et cetera
qui n'ont aucune représentation ni
syndicale ni politique et qui demandait
tout simplement à être reconnu à être
entendu et ils ont eu l'impression c'est
vrai à l'issue du grand débat national
d'avoir été parfois un peu floué
c'est-à-dire ce grand débat national a
débouché en effet sur des des des
milliers de cahers de dolérance vous
savez que tout a été numérisé donc tout
est à la disposition euh du public
simplement ça n'est pas facile d'accès
il y a eu d'autre part un site qui a été
ouvert il y a eu 2 millions de personnes
ça n'est pas rien ont participé à ce
grand débat national mais forcément ça a
les limites de toute expérience de
démocratie participative ça touche des
minorités mais c'est une grosse minorité
de millions mais enfin il y a 47
millions d'électeurs faut pas l'oublier
donc ça touche des minorités et puis
très souvent ces expériences sont
utilisées hélas un peu comme des
opérations de marketing ou ça mobilise
ça permet de calmer les populations
après ce qu'on en fait c'est beaucoup
bec beaucoup beaucoup plus modeste oui
effectivement ils prennent la poussière
démonstration avec un extrait de
reportage reportage signé Samia de chir
elle s'était rendu je crois que cétait
il y a 2 ans en sc et
Marne plus tard les fameux cahiers de
doléance remplis par les Français sont
désormais conservés dans les archives
départemental comme ici en cénémarne je
peux prendre un registre pour la commune
par exemple de boissis la Bertrand mes
souhaits pour l'Europe unifier les taxes
et impôts dans tous les pays pour éviter
les paradis fiscaux taxer les gars
femmes 50 cahiers venus des 500 communes
du département sont conservés dans une
quinzaine de boîtes théoriquement
accessibl à tous mais que personne n'est
jamais venu consulter je ne suis pas
certain non plus que le grand
public ait connaissance que ces
documents se trouvent aux archives
départementales bien entendu une
certaine communication a été assurée en
2019 sur le sujet ces documents sont des
trésors inestimables pour
comprendre la motivation des citoyens
leur colère leur proposition leur le le
sens qu'il souhait donner à la vie
publique et je suis certain que le temps
viendra où des historiens des chercheurs
se pencheront sur ces
documents non c'est surtout le drame
parce que c'est c'est que ce soit un
matériau formidable pour les futurs
historiens tant mieux mais ça devit être
un outil pour le quotidien et donc et
c'est ça qui est désolant parce que
c'était une opération politique assez
talentueuse d'Emmanuel Macron pour
rebondir et se sortir de ce bourbier
mais les gens ils l'ont fait sincèrement
ils l'ont fait de bonne foi cette
démarche de de remplir
ées détestable et effectivement je
Cassel ça pose la question de la
reconnaissance c'est ce que disait
Pascal Perino à l'instant est-ce qu'il y
a quand même parce que on peut avoir le
sentiment que dans le débat public que
ce soit chez les politiques vous disiez
Mathieu tout à l'heure ou ou même dans
le traitement médiatique on regarde un
peu plus près cette France là quand même
si on compare aujourd'hui par rapport à
il y a 5 ans donc reconnaissance ou pas
oui c'est un point central on a commencé
ce débat en parlant des de pouvoir
d'achat qui était très importante il y
avait une dimension économique dans le
le déclencheur de la crise des gilets
jaunes mais il y avait aussi vous l'avez
dit Pascal une question de
reconnaissance de fierté et de même
qu'onose trop souvent l'écologie et les
classes populaires on oppose souvent les
classe populaire des périphéries de la
ruralité au banlieu et je crois que
pendanton a fait dans la première partie
de notre émission ah bon et ben je je
la en tout cas mais mais je trouve qu'on
a de plus en plus tort parce que d'
certaine manière on a vu aussi dans le
peuple des gilets jaunes déjà enfin une
certaine naïveté vous l'avez dit c des
gens qui n'avaient jamais manifesté qui
ont vu ce que c'était d'avoir des CRS en
face d'eux ça ne se passe pas toujours
bien ça c'était relativement nouveau
dans cette France qui n'est pas la la la
la France qui pense que la police tue et
par ailleurs je crois qu'il y a eu aussi
une vraie attente de reconnaissance
j'allais dire culturelle de ce qu'on ce
que Christophe guilu avait appeler la
France périphérique dans cette France
qu'on encore une fois on oppose souvent
un peu rapidement à la France des
banlieux qui s'est d'ailleurs qui s'est
d'ailleurs fait entendre pendant en
juillet de de cette année après la mort
de de Naël par un policier ouis lucide
Schmith je je là j'ai j'ai en tête les
les deux extraits de de déclaration
d'Emmanuel Macron que SIM Jourdain nous
a nous a proposé avec C ce c'est un M à
coupa qu'on n pas si souvent entendu
dans la bouche du du du chef de l'État
sauf que ça pas vraiment alors c'est
beaucoup d'argent des milliards mais pas
de réponse structurelle alors est-ce que
c'était possible d'apporter une réponse
structurel à un mouvement aussi
hétérogène il y a plusieurs choses par
rapport à ce qu'on dit Pascal et et
Jean-Laurent quand vous lisez les
cahillettes de doléance moi il se trouve
que j'étais à Bordeaux et que il y avait
une manifestation autour de ces 5 ans
des des gilets jaunes et il y avait donc
différents euh extraits des CET doléance
qui était exposé il faut se rappeler
d'abord qu'il y a pas que les gilets
jaunes qui ont écrit dans les cett de
doléance c'est-à-dire que n'importe qui
pouvait y aller et au fond mais ceux qui
ont écrit c'est souvent ceux qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de prendre la parole et
qui ont saisi cette opportunité et donc
ce qui était assez frappant on le voyait
même dans dans votre reportage par
exemple c'est l'écriture cette écriture
ronde parfois de ces femmes de ces mères
de famille qui disent quelque chose sur
la façon dont elles ne peuvent pas au
fond donner à leurs enfants une vie
comme elle le souhaiterait ou ce père
qui dit moi je peux pas emmener ma femme
au restaurant donc il y a quelque chose
c'est certes très politique mais c'est
aussi très poignant en fait moi c'est ça
que je voulais dire et je trouve ça
dommage que d'une certaine manière même
les journalistes même les reportages ne
fassent pas état de cette ce côté
extrêmement poignant de cette douleur de
ne pas pouvoir avoir la vie qu'on
souhaiterait avoir dans ce cadre alors
la là du coup je dirais que réponse
politique réponse
possible du coup par rapport à à
Emmanuel Macron ce qui est frappant
c'est que lui aussi il veut jouer
l'empathie moi je trouve que c'est ça
qui qui est frappant il dit bah je su je
suis pas capable forcément de répondre à
tout tout de suite et cetera mais jouer
l'empathie alors que ce qui se passe
c'est que le désespoir s'appuie sur une
ABS d'absence concrète de revenu de
capacité à donner un destin de logement
et cetera si vous voulez l'empathie ne
fonctionne pas moi ça ça me semble
essentiel et en plus on attend pas
d'Emmanuel Macron qui viennent nous dire
j'ai pas réussi et cetera on attend
plutôt une réponse qui doit être assez
concrète et moi ce qui me semble
important c'est qu'il a pas
territorialisé la réponse c'estàdire que
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a échoué parce que
d'une certaine manière il a parlé d'une
position de surplomb et par rapport à ce
que disait Jean-Laurent casselli tout à
l'heure sur les lois écologiques qui
continuent à tomber du ciel c'estàdire
que les a des feux le DPE c'est des
sigles personne ne comprend et qui
tombent du ciel et qui affecte d'abord
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens donc dans
cette situation non seulement il y a pas
eu de réponse structurante mais en plus
on a l'impression que les choses se sont
installées dans la més-entente je tiens
à le dire et notamment sur le lien entre
l'écologique et le social les AFE le
DPE le trème j'oublie 3è c le zan le zan
ces
troisl c'est très éloigné entre nous de
l'univers des gilets jaunes du langage
des gilets jaunes et au fond de la
capacité à faire en sorte que les lois
écologiques s'inscrivent dans les
territoires donc à mon sens depuis 5 ans
non seulement on n' pas compris mais
d'une certaine manière on a enfoncé le
clou de la difficulté du faossé
clqu cas le clou entre les élites etux
qui et ça veut pas dire pas la recherche
d'une écologie populaire dans le peuple
français alors il y a une question
évidemment et avec le recul du temps on
a peut-être des réponses pour qui vote
les gilets jaunes Mathieu pas si simple
de répond premier renseignement pas pour
euxmême on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
un mouvement qui a été incapable de se
structurer par son caractère composiste
basiste aussi puon l'a dit il supportait
pas les représentants aussi il faut le
dire parce que système politique est
assez verrouillé en France et qui a pas
toujours facile quand on a un nouvel
entrant de de de se faire une place mais
en fait toutes les tentatives de
création de liste ou de candidature se
sont fracassé la première elle est la
plus retentissante elle est d'une
certaine façon la plus étonnante
puisqu'elle se déroule 6 mois après le
mouvement des gilets jaunes on est en
mai 2019 il y a les élections
européennes 6 mois par avant au mois de
décembre Ipsos fait une grande enquête
où il apparaît que 12 % des Français
seraient prêts à voter pour une liste
gilets jaune et qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans ces 6 mois où la mobilisation
continue et ben d'un point de vue
politique absolument rien les trois
listes parce qu'il y en a trois en fait
qui se revendiquent des gilets jaunes
euh il y en a une qui s'appelle alliance
jaune notre évolution citoyenne et puis
la dernière la liste jaune et citoyens
qui va fusionner avec celle de Philippo
de Florian Philippo pardon des patriotes
mais ces trois liste additionné ne
dépasse pas 1,3 % des voix donc d'accord
ça n'était qu'un sondage à 12 % mais
passer à ce point à quelque chose d'ossi
ratatiné alors que ce mouvement a
perduré dans la durée a mobilisé sur
d'une certaine façon l'ensemble de du
territoire et pas seulement dans dans
dans dans dans certaines régions c'est
quand même une interrogation après
européenne euré municipale 2020 il y a
une dizaine de de listes gilets jaunes
dans les villes de dans les communes de
plus de 3500 habitants mais même chose
très très mauvais résultat même si à
cette époque là on voit émerger le
succès de list citoyennees participative
de rassemblement citoyens est-ce qu'on
peut les relier ou pas à cette ce ce
gilet jaunisme d'atmosphère pour dire je
ne sais pas je sais pas si si on peut le
faire mais en tout cas il y a ça et puis
au présid présidentiel enfin au régional
il y a rien et puis au présidentiel il y
a rien il y a une tentative qui est
celle de Jacqueline mourau une des
premières gilets jaunes historiques de
se elle se déclare candidate et puis
elle finit par rejoindre Éric Zéo alors
les les gilets jaunes évidemment très
composites ils ont préféré voter pour
qui finalement alors sans surprise
d'après les enquêtes qui ont été menées
après le premier tour de la
présidentielle je pense une enquête BVA
une enquête etlab par
exemple c'est sur les partis antiystème
qu'on on profité et celle qu'on a le
plus profité ben c'est Marine Le Pen que
ce soit au premier tour de la
présidentielle on dit qu'elle rassemble
quatre gilets jaunes sur 10 en gros dans
les enquêtes qui ont voté pour elle
qu'on a bénéficié au présidentiel et
j'allais dire au législative aussi
derrière puisqu'on a vu sans que la
carte électorale enfin sans que la carte
de l'électorat de Marine Le Pen recoupe
forcément celle des rond-points et je
sais que beaucoup de gens ont travaillé
là-dessus mais globalement elle a
fortifié on va dire c'est son
implantation dans la France d'î
périphérique dans celle de des du milieu
rural est-ce que Jean-Luc mélenchan en
profite alors jeanl Marchon il arrive
derrière alors derrière Marine Le Pen en
gros le crédite entre 25 et 28 % des
voix des gilets jaunes euh lui pourtant
il avait quand même pris fait échos vous
souvenez dans sa campagne il avait dit
qu'il ad ministtiait tous les gilets
jaunes condamnés qui garantirait le
reclassement et l'indemnisation des
victimes d'amputation desborgement bref
il en avait fait beaucoup mais il
n'arrive que derrière Marine Le Pen et
puis c'est pas une immense surprise je
le disais parce que l'extr vous enfin
parce que par nous le disait tout à
l'heure l'extrême droite etextrême
gauche était aussi présent dans les
cortèges il faut le dire d dès le 18
alors l'ironie du sort c'est que les
candidats qui avaient multiplié les
appels du pied de façon très voyante je
pense à Nicolas dupontaignnon qui
revêtait gilet jaune pour aller sur tous
les rond-points ben lui évidemment ça
n'a pas marché enfin il n'a pas fédéré
autour de lui les votes de gilets jaunes
ni même éri Zemour qui avait tenté
ensuite par la suite de les récupérer
Pascal
perinos ça ne changera pas c'estàdire
que est-ce que c'est C grande tendance
dont parle dont parle Mathieu est-ce
qu'elle est-ce qu'elles peuvent
s'inscrire dans la dans la durée
c'estàdire d'abord un élector S qui va
favorablement voter pour Marine Le Pen
oui et il y a trois formes de
protestation en effet celle qui est très
dominante c'est la protestation en
faveur du rassemblement national
d'ailleurs qui s'est exprimé dès les
Européennes de 2019 voilà dès les
Européennes de 2019 la liste de Jordan
Bardella est plébiscité par les gens qui
sont des sympathisants des gilets jaunes
et loin derrière deuxième forme de
d'expression loin derrière en effet la
France insoumise et puis trisème forme
de protestation qu' faut jamais oublier
c'est l'abstention hein c'est-à-dire les
gens qui votent avec les pieds hein et
parmi les les gilets jaunes il y a un
telle distance par rapport à à la
politique et même parfois une telle
haine du monde de la représentation
politique que cette option
abstentionniste est souvent choisi mais
le fait que Marine Le Pen soit en tête
n'est pas du tout surprenant parce que
vous savez moi ce qui m'a frappé c'était
que dès sa première candidature
présidentielle c'était en 2012 contre
Sarkozy et François Hollande et à
l'époque tout le monde ricanait c'était
elle avait fait toute une partie de sa
campagne sur le prix du mazout et tout
le monde disait mais qu'est-ce qu'il lui
prend et cetera c'est ridicule et cetera
elle savait très bien qu'il fallait
s'occuper de cette France périphérique
qu'elle appelait dans sa propagande
électorale la France invisible elle
savait aussi qu'il y avait là tout un
électorat qui avait besoin de
reconnaissance et d'une certaine manière
le vote est rine che c'est une partie
des des gilets jaunes c'est cette forme
de reconnaissance on utilise le vote en
disant où on existe ouis et puis alors
on l'a déjà expliqué analysé documenté
sur ce plateau Luc Schmith mais c'est
aussi un échec de des parties de gauche
de pas avoir su capitaliser sur sur un
mouvement comme celui-là quand même ils
étaent même hostille les partis de G
alors moi je crois qu'il y a plusieurs
choses à dire d'abord c'est que je
voulais rappeler que dans la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui a créé
ensuite une association qui s'appelle
l'association des 150 un certain N de
personnes qui étaient moteurs se sont
engagé politiquement et qu'elles ont
choisi des partis politiques très divers
il y en a même qui sont devenus
macronistes et il y en a qui sont
devenus socialistes il y en a qui sont
qui simplement son à dirigé leur village
donc il y a un sujet aussi sur comment
l'engagement peut se traduire d'abord au
niveau local je voulais revenir sur le
fait que c'est un mouvement territorial
et qu'au fond choisir Marine Le Pen au
présidentiel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
sur ce qui se passe au niveau
territorial je crois que Mathieu a a dit
qu'il y avait une territorialisation des
listes locales les listes citoyennes la
question des citoyens et des listes
locales c'est un truc intéressant parce
que est-ce que ça veut dire que les
citoyens aujourd'hui avant c'était
plutôt les Verts par exemple av des
listes citoyennes est-ce que aujourd'hui
ça va être des citoyens plutôt de droite
voire plutôt d'extrême droite il y a un
vrai sujet sur qu'est-ce qui va se jouer
autour de citoyens et engagés politique
et ça il faut regarder les choses non
seulement à l'échelle présidentielle
mais à l'échelle locale deuxièmement par
rapport au Parti de Gauche la première
chose qu'on peut dire c'est on a parlé
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon on n' pas parlé
des partis au fond on a parlé des
leaders et c'est un des paradoxes sur
lequel je voulais revenir c'est que ce
mouvement des gilets jaunes il veut pas
de leader mais au fond il choisit des
Grandes Gueules quand même c'est-à-dire
qu'il choisit Marine Le Pen Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors que quand il il est prié
d'aller rencontrer édard Philippe moi je
me rappelle d'Édouard Philippe en train
de poiroter pendant 2h et qu'il y a zéro
gilets jaunes qui viennent le voir parce
que ils avaient pas réussi à désigner
des leaders pour rencontrer le Premier
ministre vous rappelez pas de cette
image donc c'est très intéressant
c'est-à-dire que ils vont du côté des
leaders grande gueule il désigent pas de
leader et il préfèrre sans doute les
listes locales citoyennes donc il y a
quelque chose comme le disait Pascal
d'inabouti sur le plan démocratique mais
ça traduit aussi la crise dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons de manière générale
je trouve qu'il représente très bien
métaphoriquement d'une certaine manière
le le merdier dans lequel nous sommes
oui et et le manque de confiance par de
l'absention le manque de confiance pour
les les parti politique écoutez ce
constat que faisait le directeur
international pour les études politiques
de Quantar public on est quelques jours
après le second tour de la
présidentielle ça ça nous dit quelque
chose de plus profond ça nous dit qu'il
y a un rapport à la politique qui est
dégradé mais ça on le constate dans les
comparaisons internationales dans la
dernière enquête Eurobaromètre qui donc
porte sur les 27 pays deunion européenne
la France ferme quasiment le banc dans
le classement des pays en fonction
de la confiance qu'ils accordent au
partis politiques on doit être à à 8 %
pour une moyenne européenne qui tourne
autour de 20 % 20 % c'est pas fameux 8 %
c'est très grave effectivement 8 % c'est
grave Jean-Laurent Cassel sur ce on
terminé ça va être notre dernier thème
cette question du on va dire renouveau
démocratique euh est-ce que c'est pas
justement la réponse qui manque le plus
c'estàd qu'on a on a vu les promesses
faites par Emmanuel Macron Steve jourin
les rappeler sur cette question du
renouveau démocratique elles sont elles
sont vraiment pas tenues oui parce que
pour boucler aussi avec votre précédent
questionnement sur la la couleur
politique des gilets jaunes c'est vrai
que c'est une question qu'on s'est tous
posé est-ce que les gilets jaunes sont
de gauche ou de droite mais en fait
c'est une mauvaise question parce que
c'est une question à laquelle on ne peut
pas répondre c'est comme s'ils étaient
dans un autre jeu vidéo que nous qui
parlons au Public Sénat de la politique
institutionnelle des médias des corps
intermédiaires ils sont dans un autre
délire quoi voilà et moi à l'époque avec
Gan forquin on avait écrit sur la la
culture des gilets jaunes sur les
humoristes dont il parlait beaucoup il y
avait Coluche il y avait l'humoriste
s'appelle la Bajon qui est très
populaire chez eux il y avait le fait
qu' qu'ils ils entamaient des petits pas
de danse sur les rond-points des
farandol des chenilles des de la
contrterie il voilà il y a quelque chose
aussi de sympathique dans tout ça mais
mais il y a aussi une critique qui est
qui est radicale de de la la politique
institutionnelle institutionnalisée au
point que donc on rent à ma question sur
l'absence de renouveau démocratique
c'est pas faute d'avoir essayéuel Macron
il arrête pas d'essayer on a parlé après
les gilets jaunes de je sais pas la
possibilité de voter sur sa console
PlayStation ou je ne sais quoi enfin
raconte n'importe quoi mais on on en est
un peu là aussi je quand Pascal Perino
faisait dresser le profil des gilets
jaunes politiquement je pensais à Cyril
Hanouna parce que Cyril Hanouna
revendique d'avoir dans son dans son
audimat des gens d'extrême droite des
gens d'extrême gauche et des
absentionnistes à peu près TR tiers
équivalent voilà donc
finalement pourquoi je parle de parce
que quand les gilets jaunes ét av voulu
forcer les plateau de télé pour pour
s'exprimer dans les premières semaines
il n'étent pas venu chez vous à Radio
France ils étaient allés directement
voir le studio de
voil que vous êtes en train de Rapp mais
vous avez tout à fait raison il y a
aucun problème je dis ça pour rire
Pascal à vous le mot de la conclusion on
est ce thème de renouveau démocratique
il y avait quand même la demande de
référendum d'initiative citoyenne il y a
un référendum initiative partagée qui
existe mais qui est une usine à gaz
inutilisable c'est là la la réforme
possible il POS ils ont posé massivement
euh la question démocratique et la
question de la nécessité de voilà de de
de reprendre notre démocratie à la fois
dans sa dimension représentative il y a
des peut-être des réformes à faire le
référendum d'initiative partagé baisser
par exemple le seuil a des choses
extrêmement concrètes à faire euh le
l'usage à nouveau
du référendum pourquoi en effet on a été
saisi d'une espèce de tétanie depuis
2005 parce que le peuple français avait
dit non enfin voilà et puis de
développer à côté d'autres formes de
démocratie plus plus permanente la
démocratie participative mais à
condition de la prendre un petit peu au
sérieux et de l'articuler concrètement
au monde de la représentation merci
beaucoup à tous j'ai rappelé les titres
de vos livr lu Schmith Emmanuel Macron à
contetemps c'est chez Bayer et Jean la
France sous nos yeux publié au Seuil
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité notez que demain l'invité de la
matinale sera niè panier run chez la
ministre de la transition énergétique
bonne
[Musique]
soirée